you went to the mecca of robotics which
is cmu carnegie mellon university you
got a phd there
so maybe by way of advice
and maybe by way of
story and memories what does it take to
get a phd
in robotics at cmu
and maybe
you can throw in there some advice for
people who are thinking about
doing work in artificial intelligence
and robotics and are thinking about
whether to get a phd it's like i
actually went i was a cmu for undergrad
as well and didn't know anything about
robotics coming in and was doing you
know electrical computer engineering
computer science and really got more and
more into kind of ai
and then fell in love with autonomous
driving and at that point like that was
just by a big margin like such a
incredible like central spot of uh
develo of investment in that area and so
what i would say is that like robotics
like for
all the progress that's happened is
still a really young field there's a
huge amount of opportunity now that
opportunity shifted where something like
autonomous driving has moved from being
very research and academics driven to
being commercial driven where you see
the investments happening
in commercial now there's other areas
that are much younger
and you see like kind of grasping and
manipulation making kind of the same
sort of journey that like autonomy made
and there's other areas as well what i
would say is the space moves very
quickly anything you do a phd in like it
is in most areas will evolve and change
as technology changes and constraints
change and hardware changes and the
world changes
um and so
the beautiful thing about robotics is
it's super broad it's not a narrow space
at all and it can be a million different
things in a million different industries
and so
it's a great opportunity to come in and
get a broad foundation on ai machine
learning computer vision systems
hardware sensors all these separate
things
you do need to like go deep and find
something that you're like really really
passionate
about obviously like just like any phd
this is like a
five six year kind of uh endeavor
and you have to
love it enough to go super deep to learn
all the things necessary to be super
deeply functioning in that area and then
contribute to it in a way that hasn't
been done before and in robotics that
probably means um more breadth because
robotics is rarely kind of like one
particular kind of narrow technology
and it means being able to collaborate
with teams where like one of the coolest
aspects of like
my the exp the experience that i kind of
cherish in our phd is that we actually
had a pretty large av project that for
that time was like a pretty serious
initiative where you got to like partner
with a larger team and you had the
experts in perception and the experts in
planning and the staff and the
mechanical challenge um so i was working
on the a project called upi back then uh
which was basically the off-road version
of the darpa challenge it was a darpa
funded project for
basically like a large off-road vehicle
that you would like
drop and then give it a waypoint 10
kilometers away and it would have to
navigate a completely instruction in an
off-road environment yeah so like
forests ditches rocks vegetation and so
it was like a really really interesting
kind of a hard problem where like wheels
would be up to my shoulders it's like
gigantic right yeah by the way av for
people stands for autonomous vehicles
vehicles yeah sorry um and so what i
think is like the beauty of robotics but
also kind of like the expectation is
that
um
there's um spaces in computer science
where you can be very very narrow and
deep
robotics one of the the necessity but
also the beauty of it is that it forces
you to be excited about that breadth and
that partnership across different
disciplines that enable it but that also
opens up so many more doors where
you can go and you can do robotics in
almost any category where robotics isn't
a
isn't really an industry it's like
it's like ai right it's like the
application of physical automation to uh
you know to all these other worlds and
so you can do robotic surgery you can do
vehicles you can do factory automation
you can do healthcare or you can do like
uh
leverage the ai around the sensing to
think about static sensors and scene
understanding so um so i think that's
got to be the expectation and the
excitement and it uh breeds people
they're probably a little bit more
collaborative and more excited about
working in teams uh if i could briefly
comment
on the fact that the robotics people
i've met in my life
from cmu and mit
they're really happy people yeah because
i think it's the collaborative thing
yeah i think i think you don't you
you're not like a sitting in like the
fourth basement uh exactly
when you're doing machine learning
purely software it's very tempting to
just disappear into your own hole yeah
and never collaborate and and there that
breeds
a little bit more of the silo mentality
of like
i have a problem it's almost like
negative to talk to somebody else or
something like that but robotics folks
are just very collaborative very
friendly just and there's also an energy
of like you get to confront the physics
of reality often which is
humbling
and also exciting so it's humbling when
it it fails and exciting when it finally
it's like the purity of the passion you
got to remember that like right now like
robotics and ai is like just all the
rage and autonomous vehicles and all
this like 15 years ago and 20 years ago
like
it wasn't that deeply lucrative people
went into robotics they did it because
they were like thought it was just the
coolest thing in the world to like make
physical things intelligent in the real
world and so there's like a raw passion
where they went into it for the right
reasons and so forth and so it's really
great space and that organizational
challenge by the way like um when you
think about the challenges in av we talk
a lot about the technical challenges the
organizational challenge is through the
roof where
you think about the challenge the what
it takes to build an av system and you
have companies that are now thousands of
people
and um you know you look at other really
hard technical problems like an
operating system it's pretty well
established like you kind of know that
there's a file system there's virtual
memory there's this there's that there's
like uh
um caching and like and there's like a
really reasonably well established
modularity and apis and so forth and so
you can kind of like scale it in an
efficient fashion that doesn't exist
anywhere near to that level of maturity
in autonomous driving right now
and tech stacks are being reinvented
organizational structures are being
reinvented you have problems like
pedestrians that are not isolated
problems they're part sensing part
behavior prediction part planning part
evaluation and
like one of the biggest challenges is
actually how do you solve these problems
where the mental capacity of a human is
starting to get strained on how do you
organize it and think about it where
you know you have this like
multi-dimensional matrix that needs to
all work together and so
that makes it kind of cool as well
because it's not like solved at all uh
from you know like what what is what
does it take to actually scale this
right and then you look at like other
gigantic challenges that have you know
that have been success successful and
are way more mature
there's a stability to it and like maybe
the autonomous vehicle space will get
there but right now just as many uh
technical challenges as they are they're
like organizational challenges and how
do you like solve these problems that
touch on so many different areas and
efficiently tackle them
while
like maintaining progress among all
these constraints
while scaling
you